Hey friends. So, when I am out and about
in the world and I'm interacting with
people at flow festivals or spin jams, I
can always tell when somebody has taught
themselves how to spin flowers. Let me
show you how I can tell. So, most people
would perform their split time opposites
anti-pin flowers like so. And at first
blush, it may not seem like there's much
going on here, but if I were to activate
some trails, so you can see the movement
of the poi together as one long
continuous stream, there's a different
story that emerges here. Still not
seeing it? Well, I tell you what. I'm
going to make one slight
tweak. Now, do you see the difference?
How about the difference between
this versus
this? In both cases, I'm just doing
something very, very slightly different,
but it makes all the world in how we get
to see the tricks that we produce as PO
spinners. So, I'm going to share with
you what that one trick is here in this
video to help you clean up your own
flowers.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I am going to
show you how you can clean up a bad
habit with your flowers that you may not
even know that you have. But before we
dive in, I just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel.
Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer, Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-B business friend of
the channel, Becca Beckon. Thank you so
much for supporting my channel, my work,
and my mission. So, I do just want to
say from the jump here that there is no
shame for folks that have picked up this
bad habit because quite frankly, if you
didn't have somebody teaching you how to
do poi from the get-go, I think it's
pretty inevitable that this is a thing
that is going to happen to you. Now,
again, I do want to just show you the
difference between these two approaches
to creating flowers. Approach number one
and approach number two makes such a
huge difference in the presentation of
these flowers now, doesn't it? So, what
is the deep dark secret how I'm doing
this? I kid you not. It's that I'm
pivoting my shoulders back and forth
here. Now, that seems like it may not
amount to much, but you wouldn't believe
how much this changes both the
presentation of your flowers and how
your body movement kind of interacts
with them as you're doing them. Okay, so
let's dissect what's going on here so we
can understand where exactly the fix
comes in. And that is that most of us
when we're first learning how to spin
poi are doing so from a place where
we're trying to avoid moving as many
parts of our body as we possibly can.
So, when we are learning to have our
hands move around in split-time
opposites in preparation for learning
how to do extensions and flowers and the
like, we're doing so from a place where
we are keeping most of our body just
solidly in place and just trying to move
around our arm from our shoulder, which
in and of itself, if you're just trying
to figure out the motion of split time
opposites, which is notoriously
difficult, then yeah, this is not a bad
place to start. But something very
quickly becomes apparently off when we
look at what happens at either side of
this pattern. Namely, if I stop my hands
on either side of me, you notice how
there's a gap between them. In fact,
that gap is pretty hard to get rid of
with our body oriented this way because
there's a gap between our shoulders.
Namely, they're shoulderswidth apart.
So, when I put my hands over to the
side, guess what? My hands also wind up
a shoulders width apart on either side
of me. Okay, so let's contrast this
versus this as I take my hands around in
split time opposites. Now all of a
sudden my hands are reaching equally far
over to either side. And most
importantly, this point in the center,
they happen to be matching up along the
same vertical line, giving us much
better symmetry and much better form
when we get to our flowers. All right.
So, how do we implement this change?
Well, step one is going to be that we're
going to have to break out of this
routine where we're trying very hard not
to move any part of our body except for
our arms. And what I'm going to give you
in order to learn how to do that is a po
trick called a giant. Now, giants are
essentially taking a split time same
direction reel like we would do in a
watermill or up high in a windmill and
performing them with our arms at full
length. That is, we can start off by say
looking over to our stage, right, and
getting our arms moving around in split
time, same direction forward. And then
when our left arm is going down past our
hips, we turn our entire body around to
our stage left and start moving our
hands around in almost like a backstroke
in split time same direction. Reverse
here when the right hand is going up
top, we follow it back around over to
stage right where we go back to
forwards. So al together we are forwards
stage right. We follow the left hand
around to reverse on stage left. And we
follow the right hand back around to
forwards on stage right. Now, the
challenge here is you need to rivet your
feet in place and only turn your upper
body back and forth as you're doing
this. And of course, we can do this with
the poi, which results in a move with
enormous amount of volume that I
personally think looks super duper cool.
And the biggest and best thing we get
out of this is that this starts to train
our body to move from our core and pivot
our shoulders back and forth as we do
the move, which is going to come in real
handy in a second here. Okay. So, now
that we have loosened up our core and
gotten ourselves used to moving our
upper body back and forth from our hips,
what comes next? Well, I'm going to have
to retrain you how to do timing and
direction in at least three different
modes in order to make all these pieces
come together. So, to start with, we're
just going to work with the basics,
namely together same. So, to do together
same, rather than just moving your hands
around in a circle, I instead want you
to start with your arms shoulderwidth
apart at your hips, and I want you to
swing them up next to your ears, and
then swing them back down next to your
hips. They go up along the sides. They
go down along the sides. It's like
they're stuck in little rails that
happen to be even with your shoulders as
you go back and forth here. We're
reaching up. We're reaching down. We're
reaching up. We're reaching down. All
right. So, what exactly does this have
to do with turning our hands together in
together? Same. Well, as it turns out,
if you swing your hands back and forth
like so, and you happen to turn your
upper body back and forth as you're
doing it, it becomes a different kind of
together same. One in which our hands
seem to move around together in which we
don't have a gap on either side of the
pattern. So, give this a try for
yourself. Think that you're going to
swing your arms up from your hips to
your ears when facing over to stage left
and then back down from your ears to
your hips when facing stage right. Up on
stage left, down on stage right, up on
stage left, down on stage right, and
then see if you can do this as just one
smooth continuous motion going back and
forth. And guess what? You've now got
together same going and no gap between
your hands on either side. Huzzah. Cool.
Now, let's do the same thing with split
time opposites. As it turns out, it's
going to be pretty similar, but instead
of swinging our hands back and forth
together, we're going to start them in
opposite places. So, one hand is going
to be up near your ear, and the other
one is going to be down next to your
hips. You're going to slice them past
each other again, even with your uh
shoulders as you go back and forth here.
It's almost like you're doing that 60s
dance called I believe this is the
mashed potato, but basically, you're
trying to keep your hands even with your
shoulders. just swinging back and forth.
This is what it looks like from the side
here. And once again, from here, we're
going to work on I'm going to slice my
right hand down and my left hand up
facing stage left. Then I'm going to
turn to stage right. Slice my right hand
up and my left hand down. Turn to stage
left. Slice the right down, the left up.
Turn back to stage right. Slice the
right up and the left down.
And when you can do this continuously,
you wind up with a version of split time
opposites that happens with your hands
together on either side. No more gaps.
Huzzah. The biggest thing to emphasize
here is whether you're doing together
same or split time opposites, whenever
you go over to one side of your body,
the opposite shoulder is pointing
towards the audience. We never want to
be in a place where our chest is
pointing towards the audience on the
side. It's always our shoulder pointed
towards the audience. That's how you get
the gap to disappear. And believe it or
not, this kind of thinking can also help
us in working on split time, same
direction, too. I almost always see
people when they first start off working
from a place where once again they're
trying to move their bodies as little as
possible and just trying to make all of
the motion happen from their shoulders.
And it results in flowers that are both
more narrow than they should be. And
also too, whichever flower is further
away from the audience inevitably
doesn't seem to reach as far as the one
that is closer to the audience. But if
we turn our upper bodies back and forth
as we perform split time, same
direction, it opens up the volume that
we're doing as we work with these
flowers. And that makes them look
prettier for our audiences. Don't you
think? And again, as you drill this, I
want you to just think that rather than
trying to swim here, you're actually
opening up your arms as far as you can
to either side. I want you to have a
visual confirmation of looking
downstage. And then as your arms switch
around, a visual confirmation of looking
upstage, looking downstage, looking
upstage. It makes the difference between
performing your flowers like
this and performing your flowers like
this. Huge, huge difference. All right,
so with this lesson out there, this
means that I will be seeing a lot more
clean flowers out at my spin jams. I
hope. Thank you all so much for
watching. Make sure to like, share,
comment, and subscribe to help other
people find this lesson and to help my
channel grow.
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for supporting my mission. You rock. And
if you would like to get your name in
the credits or access to any of a host
of amazing rewards that I have available
to my supporters, you should go check
out my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. I will leave a
link to it down in the description as
well as up in the cards. Please come
help me in my mission of bringing po
spinning and flowarts to the whole wide
world. Thank you in advance. And if you
are one of those out there that are
struggling to get down the basics of
your flowers, I have a tutorial on how
to get them down within a half an hour
that I'll go ahead and link to down in
the description as well as up on screen.
Thank you so much for watching. Make
sure to get out and flow yourselves
today and I will see you with a new
video very soon. Take care now. Peace.